[Music]
once upon a time there was a little
motivated mind it had many friends a
stable job and plenty of good ideas to
change the world
[Music]
to secure a good life for itself the
little mind got up early dressed smartly
picked up that coffee and arrived first
at work
[Music]
as time passed the mind got so good at
its routine that it got up automatically
dressed up blindly picked up that coffee
without thinking and worked without
having to pay much attention
but then the mind got so good at it all
that it stopped learning and as a result
got bored and sick and bitter
[Music]
the little mind tried everything
expensive clothes fine dining drugs
therapy scuba and skydiving but nothing
worked
the little mind kept on losing weight
and willpower until the day it didn't
get up didn't dress up didn't pick up
that coffee and didn't show up to work
it was then when it decided things had
to change not all over a sudden because
that never works but in small steps
[Music]
it started getting up earlier just by
five minutes it started dressing up
differently but only a bit it got that
coffee but not to go and it began
working a little less
[Music]
with every day that went by the little
mind got a bit more time time to try new
things time to talk to strangers time to
work on some of those crazy ideas to
change the world
and with every new experience the mind
became stronger it found a new routine
made new friends and developed a new
passion
eventually the little mind even found a
soul mate made a real family and started
a new job every once in a while it looks
at the fruits of its labor one of which
is this little story
from years of research we know that in
order to get their life effectively we
need rigid routines mental biases and
muscle memory
however we also know that to find our
passion to fall in love and to make
peace with who we are we sometimes need
to slow down and break the routines we
have built
[Music]
how about you did you change your life
find your passion and fall in love with
something or someone share your thoughts
in the comments below our little minds
are very much looking forward to reading
your story
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts